ce week-end a lieu le vernissage à la
trappe de l'association harker cette
belle association aide les artistes à
lancer leur carrière manon flier bonjour
vous en êtes la présidente bonjour à
vous alors que va-t-on pouvoir découvrir
ce week-end du côté de trappes donc on
expose huit artistes du collectif de
l'association qui représente environ une
quarantaine d'oeuvres peintures
sculptures graphiste et
ce sont des artistes plutôt jeunes qui
commencent tout juste où c'est un peu un
peu de tout âge des artistes de tout
âges de tous milieux et de tous niveaux
enfin quand même on essaye de chercher
un professionnalisme et un intérêt qui
transpire attrapé à travers les oeuvres
alors comment vous est venue l'idée en
fait de parrainer un peu ces artistes
vers cette association donc tout
simplement parce que
beaucoup d'artistes pense qu' il manque
de temps pour rechercher des lieux
d'exposition adaptés à leurs oeuvres
c'est difficile de démarcher les lieux
publics et ils ont des difficultés à se
représenter en général c'est pas
toujours évident et c'est pas souvent
lucratif pour eux et c'est leur première
exposition à ces artistes qui vont venir
du côté de trappes où ils ont ils ont
déjà l'habitude justement d'exposer ils
ont déjà l'habitude d'exposer ce sera
leur première ce dernier fait un
vernissage via l'association et alors
est ce que les visiteurs pourront
acheter les oeuvres qui seront qui
seront présentées ou c'est juste une
visite simple oui bien sûr ils peuvent
venir visiter regardez admirez
discuter rencontrer les artistes et bien
sûr s'ils ont des coups de coeur les
ventes sont libres et bien sûr et alors
vous avez créé l'association parce que
je crois que vous êtes un petit peu
artiste vous même c'est ça c'est un peu
sa tête et ce quel est votre spécialité
nous moi je dessine le fusain quand
papier il a pastel sèche dessin
traditionnel nu
femmes cornu voilà cette association
harker vous l'avez crée aussi parce que
vous pensez que l'art n'est pas assez
accessible de nos jours ou que les
gentils aller les français ne s'y
intéresse pas c'est c'est pas par manque
d'intérêt je pense que ça fait un peu
peur le on se dit toujours l'art s'est
associée la richesse c'est cher etc
je veux casser cette image là et ramener
là en fait vers le public et leur
montrer que ça peut être accessible
facilement qu'on est alors ce qui va
être exposée donc vous m'avez parlé de
deux sculptures de peinture de
graphismes aussi c'est de l'art abstrait
plutôt qu'elle quel genre d'armes
inquiet du tout
on parle vraiment d'art contemporain
semto comprends c'est pour tout visiteur
lambda finale oui et puis de toute façon
les artistes seront présents sur place
pour en plus exprimé leurs oeuvres en
fait leur état d'esprit quand ils ont
par leurs peintures ou sculpter leur
leurs sculptures et alors est ce que
pour une association comme la vôtre
comme comme marqueur c'est compliqué de
trouver des lieux pour effectuer ses
vernissages ses expositions sur saint
quentin en yvelines où ça restera
accessible non je pense que ça va être
pas mal accessible quand même parce que
saint quentin en yvelines beaucoup de
lieux d'exposition
dédié à l'art contemporain est quand
même très ouvert donc je pense que l'on
va pouvoir va pouvoir aller faire des
bonnes démarches après dans l'avenir
alors l'espoir de ces artistes qui
viennent justement lors de ce vernissage
attrape ses pouvoir vraiment se lancer
derrière et c'est un peu un pied à
l'étrier comment dit alors ils sont déjà
actifs eux mêmes de leur côté pour les
expositions les choses comme ça c'est un
ensemble en fait on
je suis là aussi pour les représenter
diffuser leurs oeuvres donc derrière on
a une aura en fait une autre exposition
de prévu à paris dans le xviième voilà
très bien donc le vernissage ce week-end
c'est de 9 heures à 18 heures c'est ça
dans la zone dubuisson de la kul attrape
ses services à 3 rue eugène enough avis
aux amateurs merci à vous merci beaucoup
à vous d'être d'être venu sur le plateau
ces vigiles et puis on suivra donc c'est
de ce vernissage ce week-end merci
beaucoup après plus de deux ans de
travaux le signer cette d'elancourt a
enfin ouvert ses portes mercredi et pour
le plus grand bonheur des premiers
téléspecteurs des premiers spectateurs
aurélia de bissy et patrick jacques de
dixmude rocky leurs premières
impressions
le ciné s'est taillé en cours à bienne
ouvert ses portes au public ce mercredi
3 avril 18 mois de travaux auront
finalement permis au cinéma d'être
entièrement rénové
le public a pu découvrir des écrans plus
larges de nouveaux fauteuils un accès
aux trois niveaux par l'ascenseur et
enfin une troisième salle qu'en pense
alors les spectateurs à la sortie des
toutes premières séances
depuis le temps qu'on attendait ça
commence à être long voilà mais je
trouve que c'est très bien qu'on est
bien installé on a de la place là on est
content au niveau du son il est parfait
au niveau du film et et puis l'accueil
et jolie là maintenant ça change un
petit peu quoi d'abord chez c'est très
beau chez spacieuse c'est glee c'est non
non c'est très agréable très adverse et
je suis contente d'avoir été une des
premières à l'inaugurer
cinéma de proximité qui a les allures
d'un grand seule la politique tarifaire
reste inchangé 6 euros le billet plein
tarif
ma seconde invitée de cette week-end
vient de nous rejoindre marie elodie
royer bonjour à vous vous êtes
l'organisatrice de la vente de tissus ce
week-end à voisins le bretonneux et donc
j'imagine que pour vous tissu toile soit
ça n'a aucun sens aucun secret beaucoup
de secrets
alors justement c'est la troisième vente
que vous organisez on va essentiellement
trouver des tissus made in france je
crois c'est un peu la particularité
c'est beaucoup de made in france en fait
je fais ce travail qu'un négociant en
tissus quitterait récupère les tissus de
grandes entreprises françaises dont on
ne veut pas nommer les marques mais
voilà donc il me propose d'aller d'une
très belle soit ils arrivent à faire
venir un grand arrivage de coton comme
il ya beaucoup de monde au niveau du
coton en région parisienne donc voilà et
alors pourquoi avoir choisi justement ce
créneau du made in france parce qu'on
sait que c'est très à la mode vous
pensez que ça peut marcher plus que des
tissus qui peuvent venir d'asie par
exemple mais c'est la qualité d'abord le
made in france sont des avions depuis
des générations une qualité de tissu
très important qui qui sont très belles
et on peut pas il faut garder ce savoir
faire et cette qualité dans le pays
alors à savoir faire et une qualité donc
vraiment supérieur comme vous venez de
le souligner mais un prix défiant toute
concurrence je commence je savais à peu
près vous avez des prix très
intéressants par exemple pour la somme
vous retrouver à 8 2 euros le mètre
maximum pour une très belle soie qui
pour faire un prix équivalent sur le
marché traditionnel c'est moins 50% à
peu près sont à peu près de 150% c'est à
peu près pas ce que vous comptez à peu
près pour la même chose je compte à peu
près 20 euros le mètres dans certains
endroits en france à paris et alors là
vous êtes venu avec pas mal pas mal de
l'échantillon canton préparer l'émission
je vous ai tout de suite demandé comment
représentant la qualité d'un tissu faire
comment on reconnaît la qualité d'un
tissu donc à part premièrement
c'est le toucher le toucher chaque et
offre un toucher différents pour savoir
sa composition il faut un petit peu
brûlé le tissu pour savoir la
composition parce que des fois on a le
temps presse et de la soif en fait c'est
pas de la soie c'est un mélange de
polyester ou ninon avec de la matière
naturelle mais bon il faut vérifier
quand même parce qu'on peut vous vendre
très bien à soi qu'en fait c'est pas de
la soie donc à vérifier ils ont sur un
des tissus là vous pouvez nous montrer
expliquer moi sur celui là là où il y a
plein de petits massifs et des infos
c'est pas un vrai liberty mais c'est un
peu un aspect dit bertie donc assez un
coton donc c'est un coton est donc en
fait il faut vraiment à faire attention
quand le travail de faire attention au
sens du tissu voilà là on a un tissu
c'est plutôt un
alors ça c'est un taffetas un tapis
cette attaque n'a donc c'est un tapis
taki et qui en fait qui a été un peu fou
qu'a était floqué en fait avec des
points velours donc ça c'est une très
belle matière un très bon très bonne
qualité voilà
voilà
et puis alors là en fait on a
l'impression que c'est de la soie mais
c'est pas de la soie c'est un mélange
d'acétate
et en fait on a cet aspect soit mais
c'est pas là soit donc vous faire il
faut savoir mais c'est pas de la soie et
là je voulais vous montrer un super beau
tissu d'ameublement voilà ce que c'est
un vraiment c'est un tissu d'ameublement
qui vient des deux grandes entreprises
françaises et c'était des tissus qui
sont fabriqués sont en soi soit en lin
et qu' il ya un espèce très beau ce soit
a fait alors vous me disiez l'autre tout
à l'heure que vous brûlez diminue alors
vous brûler non pas nantis su comment on
fait un petit échantillon de tissu
moment là j'ai pas un briquet sur moi
parce que c'est pas alors l'endroit mais
vous prenez un petit morceau de tissu
vous brûlez par exemple si vous prenez
du coton vous allez avoir si saint jean
qui est très très serré ça va faire une
certaine poussière et ça fait une
poussée être abolie très lentement que
ça va faire une poussière assez noir si
vous prenez de la soie ça va faire une
poussière et c'est très légère avec une
odeur de
un peu sainte et un petit comme expliqué
brodeur je sais pas mais c'est une
certaine odeur qui est qu'on reconnaît
la soie est par exemple si vous êtes en
train de brûler la laine vous avez une
odeur de cornes d'accord voilà donc en
fait selon ça vous pouvez sa deviner la
composition et puis ça fait des bulles
pourrais vous dire que c'est du
synthétique et alors ce week-end pendant
pendant cette vente de tissus il y aura
des animations jeux président voilà des
cours de couture
je serai là bas donc pour donner les
conseils de couture il y aura les patchs
heures pour pouvoir après avoir des
techniques de patchwork il y aura aussi
un des accessoires pour enfants et des
vêtements pour enfants il y aura aussi
des pas les créateurs que j'aide aussi à
se développer donc il y aura reuil deux
as qui vend des t-shirts et des polos et
et puis une à une de mes amies qui en
fait qui lance sa saison entreprises et
qui essaye d'avoir un blog ou un
vêtement par semaine et alors au milieu
de toutes ces années le dos d'issue tel
budget on peut prévoir pour venir ce
week-end or m sombre il ya bien sûr
entre 50 et 70 euros par heure pour
aller pour des pour dix mètres de tissu
très bien on va écouter on verra ça tout
ça ce week-end et puis on découvrira
tous ces tissus donc du côté de deux
voisins bretons restée c'est un voisin
de retenue merci beaucoup marine royale
venait d'être venu ce jour sur le bateau
dériver chitray d'instruction etc merci